and initiate sequence
[Music]
mauriz are made of this what is this
place
I'm sorry to be the one to tell you this
but you got yourself killed at rst we'd
rebuild the most important assets in the
US military soldiers like yourself
you're the first who we successfully
managed to bring back but improved
enhanced with the technology of your
veins you have an army inside you that
will not only make you stronger you will
heal you instantly for
now tell me do you remember anything
where you going
I got unfinished business I'm gonna find
the man who murdered my wife and killer
[Music]
that's not good all right sundown
and initiate sequence okay who is the
next target for elimination
these are made of they tell me do you
remember anything do I know you guys I
don't think so
I've been manipulating you
what you think is real sometimes ain't
and initiate sequence
[Music]
you control me for
you sure about that
revenge is what makes a man like you
exceptional
think about men like me
[Music]
is absolutely fantastic
like I just heard this are they playing
assembly people
[Music]